Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome to "Solitude"
IS SOMEONE WALKING BY MY WINDOW OVER THERE!!
I don't take not- too kindly to that
because I'm a solitary person.
Listening to music. Read my emails?
*Reads letter onscreen*
"Tonami?"
What?!
You just said yesterday was really cool!
Why do you gotta go through the whole rest of the email insulting me?
Well this is off to a flying start!
My goodness!
Well
I'm really sad that I opened that particular email.
Oh man
Is this about the story of someone who has like social anxiety
or something like that and they actually can't get out
Oh that's weird
That's trippy!
Okay then
Cause that's fascinating if it is
I don't know!
I-I-I'm literally one minute into this game and I'm already trying to
get a meaning to this
Why not get some sunlight!
It's a beautiful day!
With a weird polygonal sun going on out there
but I don't know
What else do we have?
There's gotta be something else right?
Read the diary
*Reads letter onscreen*
Well you're not gonna be able to see him again if you're stuck in that room!
That's so weird
But then again!
If that's the guy
That
You wanna go out on a date with
That guy's an asshole
That guy's a dickbag
and I'm pretty sure you can do better than that
At least you're eating healthy
Man
There's gotta be something else to this right?
It can't just be about this
Grab, throw?
What?
Huh?
Oh!
I've got a picture of a guy facepalming
Well that's good!
This is my wine for my solitary adventure
Oh man!
This game is getting more and more depressing by the second!
Oh!
I hope those are condoms
If they're not then they're priceless rubes!
Ok
Oh geez!
I don't need to wreck up my room-
Why is there a crack in my wall?
Huh
Can I throw something at that?
EEE!
No
That didn't work
Well
That didn't work either
HEW
Well! I got the magic teleporting- Oh!
Well that's lovely!
This is just lovely!
Oh that's my closet
Oh no. It's my walkway
*Reads note onscreen*
Who wrote this note?
Did you write this note for yourself?
No!
You gotta get out there! In the public
Live life! Love life to live love life
I don't know what else I'm gonna throw if I'm just gonna mess up-
Lemme put on my fedora
Ah yes, now I feel like me
Lemme put on my other fedora
Ah yes! Oh now I am a true gentleman and a maybe lady
Don't leave the room?
Well that's really creepy
You know I opened this door expecting there to be maybe a hallway and an apartment complex
and still I got an insulting message and a ominous warning
So um...
Ok!
Ee!
What's that?
I want to sleep
No I don't
No I- No I- No I don't!
Tha-That message is not getting any closer
I have to stay
No no I don't
No no no
Nobody loves me
I love me!
And that's all that matters!
I must study
Well that's probably important
That's not for me
I am too lonely
I must study
I wanna stay home
Geez
Oh geez
Oh geez!
I am out in an ocean of darkness
What if I say something stupig?
Ha
Don't say that!
Don't say that definitely!
Oh
I only hope this is where I'm supposed to go because otherwise I am going to be lost!
*Ominous background music*
What the fuuuuudge?
*Background sounds intensifies*
Uh
Well I reached the wall
*intense music continues*
What do I do now?
Uh geez
Can you stop the Gregorian chant in my ears?
Oh
*whispers are heard from the dark*
Ok I don't know where I'm going right now but-
This is so weird
It's so weird
What do I do?
*whispers* It's so weird
I'm so lonely I'd rather-
Nobody waits for me
There will be people
I'd rather stay in my room
Man
But what do I do?
I walked all that way
I have to close the door
I'm too ugly?
Wait. I have to close the door
Did I- di- Is that why it didn't let me go through?
Cause I forgot to close the door?
Well lemme just go on my way then
Close this door
Yeah!
I closed it!
I did it and I'm free
Oh B
Oh me oh my
AHHH
I'm so angry
Beehh
Oh
Sorry about the sissy throw
What do you want from me?!
I don't know what you want!
Oh!
Oo!
This might be
Maybe
Oh
Woah. What was that?
Thought I saw something
Uhh I didn't see anything
Ok
Oo!
Wait a minute
I have an idea!
(singing) I have and idea!
I have an idea
Get out of my life!
How about- How about you too, diary?
What did the soul say?
Down the corridor to the left
I don't have a corridor out there
I don't have anything
Get out of my life!
You're ruining my *breaks voice* life!
Ok
Hang on
This might be it
Well this might be a thing
But what happens if I throw everything out?
Ahh
Ahhh
No?
Come on
Throw
I was almost correct in putting on my fedora
Wear a coat?
Hey! I didn't know I could wear a coat!
Nice!
I'm wearing a coat!
Can I wear a hat?
I kinda threw out everything else
I don't think that that's how it's supposed to be
Ee!
Sure is convenient to throw the trash a- Oh what is that?
Oh that's my phone
Fuck you phone!
Hehbeh
Get outta here!
You too! Get outta here
Get all the way outta here
Oh!
Don't sass me bruh
This stool though
This stool can go
Throw out these-
condoms
This lube
Something tells me this probably isn't the correct answer
Something tells me that I may have just ruined my entire apartment
By trying to throw everything away
Well goddammit I won't be thwarted
I did put on a coat though
So that's nice
Ok and with this LAST book
BUUHH
I have officially thrown out every single gosh darn thing in this room out into the black void of the abyss
But I can't find anything else even remotely close to what I'm supposed to be doing
I did a lot of cleaning
And it looks lovely and barren
But I don't know if there's anything else that I'm actually supposed to be doing
There's this mysterious crack in the wall
But I don't think that's going to help me at all
So, honestly I have no idea if the game's only supposed to be
An idea about the feeling of isolation
and more of an emotive game than anything
but I wanna find out-
I'm gonna look up to see if I could find out if there is an ending first
before I call this one because
I really wanna know!
Why!
Why in the fuck can't I leave the room
Ok
So I cannot seem to figure it out
and I looked up and apparently no one else has either
and the developer isn't even saying if there is an end to the game
even though there are trophies or achievements for
finally finding freedom
I don't understand how that's possibly done
so what I'll take from this is more of an interpretive style
of like
what it means to have social anxiety
and want to be alone all the time
or not even want to be alone
but be forced to by your own emotions
so that's the only interpretation that I can take out of the game
but I hope you enjoyed it nonetheless
because it's so fascinating to see like
these artistic games
it-it-it's interesting and in a sense
I feel like this could be fleshed out a lot more
and I think the developer is actually going to flesh it out a lot more
but I feel like
it's on the right path
the exploration and just kind of like putting you
in the shoes of someone who is this way
and they're un-apologetically that way
that is just who they are
and it is what it is
But either way that's all the time I've got for this video
I'm not gonna keep trying on this one so
Thank you everybody so much for watching
And as always!
I will see you in the next video
Buh-Bye!!